[Música]
es apropiado suponer en educación
es una pregunta que me hice ya hace
algún tiempo cuando estaba a cargo de un
primer año de escuela secundaria en
donde habiendo promediado el primer
trimestre de clase había un grupo de
alumnos con bajo rendimiento escolar
me parecía importante investigar para
poder
y hacer las cosas bien y no suponer nada
planteé al equipo de gestión la
posibilidad de iniciar una investigación
sobre este caso sobre todos casos y
comunique a mis colegas
una vez autorizado esto
cuál es el sentido de lo que íbamos a
hacer
había que seleccionar un método que nos
permitiera hacer este trabajo elegí la
investigación-acción porque en el ámbito
educativo nos daba un espacio de poder
compartir juntamente con las personas a
la que uno estaba haciendo el
seguimiento y tenía una herramienta que
me parecía más que importante que era la
entrevista
entonces poder entrevistarse uno
personalmente con otra persona que daba
la posibilidad de no solo escuchar el
lenguaje coloquial sino también ver ese
lenguaje que tiene que ver con lo
postural con el cuerpo con lo que el
cuerpo transmite cuando uno quiere
también a su vez transmitir una idea
así fue como empezamos a convocar a las
familias de estos chicos y una
particularidad bastante interesante de
esto es que todos venían vestidos de la
misma manera y yo dije no se pueden
estar poniendo de acuerdo y venir todos
vestidos de la misma manera claro estas
familias trabajaban en empresas
procesadoras de pescado y venían vestido
con su ropa de trabajo porque no les
daban permiso para acercarse a la
escuela en jornadas estamos hablando
entre 10 y 14 horas
entonces venían como podían y pobres se
disculpaban porque su ropa estaba sucia
lógicamente ropa de trabajo y con mucho
dolor nosotros le comentábamos que esto
no influya para nada en el sentido de la
entrevista y que valoramos que pudieran
tener trabajo poníamos en valor esos que
ellos estaban haciendo
que se notaba en estas entrevistas mucha
preocupación por que sus hijos pudieran
estudiar y pudieran cerrar esta etapa de
la escuela secundaria
pero a su vez también comentaban que
estos chicos eran todos hermanos mayores
menos uno que tenía un hermano mayor que
él eran todos hermanos mayores que
colaboraban en sus casas y que atendían
a sus hermanos menores de qué manera
haciéndoles de comer ellos estudiaban a
la mañana volvían a sus casas preparaban
a los chicos que estudiaban a la tarde
los traían a la escuela les daban de
comer previamente los venían a buscar a
las cinco de la tarde y en el medio
volvían sus papis de trabajar a los que
también atendían
porque decían los papás que valoraban la
escuela porque ellos no querían que a
los chicos les pase de alguna manera ha
dicho en términos de los padres lo que
le estaba pasando a ellos
el trabajo es muy duro en los ambientes
comunes hay entre 3 y 4 grados pero las
cámaras 54 grados bajo cero y entonces
una expresión muy de ellos era se te
rompe el cuerpo yo no quiero que a mi
hijo le pase lo mismo
por supuesto que escuchando todas estas
cosas con distintos por ahí con
distintas opiniones de uno y de otro
pero todo cerraba de la misma manera
todos parecían que les estaba pasando lo
mismo todos estos hermanitos tenían una
función muy importante en su hogar que
era permitir que sus papás pudieran
salir a trabajar todo este tiempo
pero como uno siempre se permite dudar
entonces que hicimos empezamos a
convocar a los chicos y hacer las
entrevistas con ellos
lo primero que le dijimos a los chicos y
les contamos era que ya sabíamos todo lo
que hacían en la casa y siempre
poniéndolo en valor pero también le
dijimos que era importante que fueran a
la escuela y queríamos saber si era el
mismo discurso que había en la familia y
era exactamente lo mismo mi papá no
quiere que cuando fuésemos grande nos
pisen la cabeza como a ellos que se
pelean por las mesas de trabajo que a
veces van al trabajo y los echan le
dicen que no hay que no hay trabajo
entonces por eso nos dicen todo el
tiempo que estudiemos
y entonces cuando uno escucha estas
cosas
les pedí a los chicos autorización para
poder socializar esto que le estaba
pasando a ellos porque
soy un convencido que los problemas
empiezan a resolver cuando podemos
ponerlo en palabras
y de esto no no tengo dudas
cuando en una oportunidad comenté esto
en el aula con los demás compañeros era
realmente increíble la cara de asombro
de sus compañeros de aquellos que no
tenían esta responsabilidad no podían
creer que estos chicos hagan todo eso
que estaban haciendo
y empezó a cambiar la dinámica del curso
sin que nadie proponga nada ellos solos
muchos ofrecían sus carpetas completas
para los chicos que tenían porque estos
chicos también tenían un hacer un
ausentismo importante
ofrecía en sus carpetas ofrecían cambiar
los lugares de encuentro los chicos
solos y acá nadie propuso nada
entonces
decían tus hermanitos van a la escuela
entre la una y las cinco podemos ir a tu
casa en vez de que vos te tuvieses que
trasladar y porque si no si llegan antes
tus hermanos tener que ir a buscarlo y
empezaron a cambiar las dinámicas
pero creo que no alcanzaba con esto
las prácticas docentes también tenían
que acomodarse a esto
porque si no sería muy injusto para
estos chicos
que todos iban a hacer un esfuerzo mayor
para mejorar la calidad de sus
compañeros para mejorar el rendimiento
de estos chicos y nosotros los docentes
seguimos haciendo las mismas cosas
acá hay una frase que yo escuché hace
algún tiempo que dice si siempre haces
lo que siempre insiste siempre obtendrás
lo que siempre obtuviste entonces había
que cambiar la práctica docente había
que empezar a mirar la práctica docente
de otro lugar y poder entender que esos
chicos aprovechar los espacios que
teníamos con ellos entonces cuando
venían cambiar la dinámica de clase
hace algún tiempo
escuche
un cuento que hoy le quiero contar una
señora
decide viajar a españa se acerca a la
ventanilla de la aerolínea y pide dos
pasajes en primera
cuando la empleada le pide la
documentación entregas solo su
documentación
y la empleada le dice pero me pidió dos
pasajes en primera si señorita viajo yo
con mi mono federico
sus monos federico nos puede dejar en
primera señora está prohibido que un
mono viaje en primera discúlpeme
señorita dice yo soy una persona con
muchas influencias mi marido fue
embajador en españa por lo tanto no voy
a tener ningún problema de si hablo con
algún gerente de la empresa conseguir
que mi mono federico viaje junto conmigo
en primera
bueno señora mire eso escapa mi
posibilidad llama un responsable de la
empresa
conversar un rato y llegan a un acuerdo
el mono no viaja asentado en primera
pero si viaja en una jaula con
determinadas medidas al lado de las
azafatas y con un cobertor llegado el
momento de viajar esta señora viene con
su mono federico
la jaula con las medidas que les
pidieron un cobertor marrón y con letras
doradas decía
le indican a esta mujer poner el mono al
lado de las azafatas
y las azafatas
le dicen a la señora que se van a
encargar del mono que se quede
absolutamente tranquila
despega el avión a las 2 horas el
capitán le dice miren el mono se nos
llega a pasar algo al mono estamos todos
en problemas
vale azafata dice bueno que desee
tranquilo le voy a dar un poco de agua y
fruta para que conozca destapa la jaula
y el mundo estaba muerto
capitán perdemos todo el trabajo que
pasó se murió el mono como se murió el
mono pero si les voy a dar de comer y el
mundo está muerto que quiere quedado
está muerto no no no no no pero lo
tenemos que resolver bueno veamos cómo
lo resolvemos sacarle una foto al mono
total todos los monos son iguales en
españa' conseguimos un mono hacemos el
cambio y vemos dice sí sí pero hay una
particularidad el mono tiene la cola
cortada corta en él la cola al mono
truck un mono con cola cortada pero le
falta una paleta le falta a la paleta
izquierda a perfecto dice agarraron al
mono que consiguieron sacar el diente ya
estaba el mono para el cambio todos los
monos son iguales porque se tiene que
dar cuenta
bueno llegado el momento
si al momento de aterrizar en españa
y resulta de que la mujer baja por donde
bajan los pasajeros y el mono lo bajan
por la bodega para poder hacer el cambio
y poner el mono en condiciones para
darle a la señora llega a toda la
tripulación orgullosa con el mono se
encuentran con la señora y de señora acá
está
muchas gracias dice la señora destapa
así y no mira el capital dice éste no es
federico
como señora que no es federico usted
dejó a federico y usted dice que no es
federico no este no es federico señora
si todos los bonos son iguales me quiere
decir que le vio para darse cuenta que
no es federico
es que federico estaba muerto y yo lo
llevaba para que descanse junto con los
restos de mi esposo en madrid como él me
lo había pedido
es importante
no suponer con qué equipaje han del otro
porque si no puedo que hasta influir o
hacerle creer a él con qué equipaje anda
o decirle que tiene o no qué hacer con
ese equipaje
decía baltasar gracián visto un león es
tan visto todos pero visto un hombre
solo está visto uno y encima mal
conocido y ahora digo yo hay una escuela
posible que atienda a estas necesidades
de los alumnos sí sí que la hay es una
escuela que abraza que contiene que
escucha el silencio de aquellos que no
pueden hablar o expresarse y lo pone en
palabras
es una escuela que reconoce al otro como
un verdadero otro
y esto depende exclusivamente de los
docentes que habitamos
y para eso tenemos que tener una fuerte
empatía con el alumno y con el
sufrimiento social muchas gracias
[Aplausos]